as things heat up between kim kardashian
and pete davidson a source tells e.t why
their relationship works i love that the
source explains that the 41 year old kkw
beauty founder has a great time with the
28 year old saturday night live star
adding quote he makes her laugh plays
around and has a sense of humor it is
nice for kim to be around that i love
that energy in my life and on top of all
that e.t sore says pete knows how to
talk to kim explaining quote he is the
most confident guy but not cocky it is
why it works with them kim thinks pete
is super sexy and likes how he knows so
much about comedy since that is a world
she doesn't know as much about so just
how serious are things between kim and
pete e.t source says kim is just going
with the flow but they are spending so
much time together and things are quote
really good right now it's really lit
and fun and crazy this all comes after
the two jetted off for a quick getaway
to the bahamas together last week at the
time a source told et they have a busy
few months of work ahead of them and
wanted to sneak in a little quality time
before things ramp up yes
of course the two first sparked romance
rumors back in october after kim's
hosting gig on snl
i mean i like you just the way you are
now are you gonna kiss me or not i sure
am jasmine
and ever since they've been spotted
together in la new york palm springs and
of course that bahamas vacay it's always
so much fun still neither kim nor pete
has publicly confirmed their
relationship and their friends and
family they're staying tight-lipped too
oh boy on new year's eve kim's mom kris
jenner avoided answering questions about
her daughter's romance with a little
help from granddaughter stormy during a
virtual appearance on andy cohen and
anderson cooper's new year's eve special
on cnn you know everyone is talking
about kim's new relationship with pete
davidson have you had the chance to
spend time with them how are they as a
couple
i know
that's a little stormy um
hey stormy oh
um you sit right here um yeah so
storming nice distraction good timing
stormy perfect
right on you and when e.t caught up with
the comedian's snl co-star alex moffitt
he played coy when asked about the
couple i don't really stay up to date
with what my good friend pete's up to as
long as he's having fun and he's happy
that's all i care about he's a love then
there's machine gun kelly who's super
close with pete he straight up dodged
questions about the pair with an
official no comment gotta ask you your
boy pete davidson and kim kardashian how
happy are you for him
but we're happy and while no one's
officially commenting on kim and pete's
love a source previously told et that
the comedian goes out of his way to make
the reality star feel special quote kim
thinks pete is hysterical and he's
constantly making her laugh but they
also have been connecting on a deeper
level
at the end of the day life is about
being happy so how does kim's ex kanye
west feel about his estranged wife's new
romance
i'm just extremely happy can you tell by
my face
a source previously told et he isn't too
thrilled by it but is doing his best to
stay distracted busy and fulfilled with
his own life and last week the grammy
winner posed for these sexy pda-packed
pics with uncut gem star julia fox for
interview magazine i mean it was just
fun do something for my heart it was
really surreal the snaps were taken on
their second date in new york city and
julia told the mag quote i don't know
where things are headed but if this is
any indication of the future i'm loving
the ride
[Music]